foreign
I'm speaking to you from the United
States and my mind is often on the
United States I'm speaking to you as a
historian of Eastern Europe among other
things a historian of Ukraine so that is
that helps a bit to Define where I'm
coming from so the topic that I've been
asked to address is whether democracy is
in Decline whether democracy is doomed
and what can we do I think where I'd
like to start is with the question
itself with the word democracy and how
we think about the word democracy what I
worry about is when we treat democracy
as a noun as a thing and ask questions
about it is it advancing is it receding
is it ascending is it declining we are
separating it from ourselves in a way
which is unhelpful democracy is not
really out there in the world as a thing
democracy if it exists at all exists
inside US democracy has to begin with a
desire for the people to rule which of
course is what democracy is all about so
I tend to think that in a way it's it's
more useful to think of democracy as a
verb rather than as a noun I realize
grammatically that's incorrect but I
think you understand the spirit of what
I mean the democracy is something that
you do it's something that when you
speak the word you have to be taking
responsibility for it because when
you're talking if you're talking about
something that's just out there in the
world something that's a result of of
larger forces something that's a result
of some constellation of influences it
doesn't have to do with you or with the
people then you're not really talking
about democracy or what's worse if we
talk about democracy as something that's
out there in the world as something
that's a result of larger forces such as
for example capitalism I think we're not
just making an analytical mistake I
think we're also committing a kind of
ethical and political suicide I think
the moment that we say democracy is a
result of larger forces democracy is
somehow natural democracy is a default
State of Affairs we're not just making a
mistake
um we're we're making ourselves into the
kinds of people who aren't going to have
a democracy so to be clear about what I
mean
um obviously there are some conditions
which favor or don't favor a democracy I
wouldn't doubt that
um modernity does tend to bring larger
scale politics it makes democracy
possible perhaps but it certainly
doesn't bring it capitalism is certainly
consistent with democracy there are
plenty of capitalist democracies but
there are also plenty of states that are
capitalist and are quite tyrannical so
capitalism is consistent with democracy
but it doesn't bring us democracy and I
think in the west at least and
especially in the English-speaking West
this has been one of the chief mistakes
of the last three decades to believe
that larger Forces in general or
capitalism in particular are going to
bring us democracy the belief which was
so widespread after the Revolutions of
1989 or the end of the Soviet Union in
1991 that there were no Alternatives or
that history was over
the problem with that I think we've seen
in the last 30 years is that if you
think democracy is being brought to you
then you lose the sense that democracy
is a struggle as it always has to be as
Frederick Douglass said you lose the
muscles and even the muscle memory of
what it means to carry out that struggle
and maybe slightly more subtly but also
really importantly you lose the past and
you lose the future because if you think
that democracy is inevitable that it's
somehow being brought about by larger
forces well then all those things that
happen in the past don't really matter
they just kind of become cocktail party
conversation and if you're sure that
there's only one future a democratic
future then you lose the habit and the
ability to talk about multiple possible
Futures and you also along the way lose
the capacity for recognizing other kinds
of political systems as they emerge as
they have emerged in the 21st century
and then finally and this is this is a
little tricky but I think it's quite
crucial you also lose your ability to
process facts we're in a world where the
whole notion of factuality is questioned
and I think this is related to our
problem of democracy if you if you think
that democracy is coming inevitably if
you tell stories about for example
historical arcs that have to tend in a
certain direction then what you'll tend
to do is move the facts so that they fit
the narratives and soon we find
ourselves only talking about narratives
and not talking about facts or we find
ourselves in countries that claim to be
democracies but no longer have the
journalists who are out there producing
the facts that we need to have for
democracy so
um so we have what we have I mean the
answer the question is democracy doomed
no obviously we can do things but is it
in Decline certainly by any measurable
by any by any by any meaningful metric
democracy's decline in my home country
and on average around the world and
we're also in a very specific situation
where a non-democracy Russia is fighting
to destroy a democratic country Ukraine
which is a sign that things have gone
pretty far
now the ukrainians I would suggest have
given us some indication of what we
ought to be doing
what the ukrainians are doing and
resisting this invasion is that they're
resisting the larger forces if we think
back to the beginning of the war
everyone assumed that Ukraine would
collapse in a few days that was the
wisdom not only in Moscow but also in
Washington DC in defending the basic
idea that you choose your own leaders
um the ukrainians are reminding us that
democracy isn't about the larger forces
it often involves ignoring the larger
forces resisting larger forces ignoring
the people who tell you that it can't be
done and here I think we see a sign of
our crisis which is that many people at
least in my country and I think more
broadly the reason why they thought that
the president of Ukraine the Vladimir
zolenski would flee or the reason they
thought that the ukrainians wouldn't
resist is that they themselves would
have fled and they themselves wouldn't
have persisted that is to say the idea
that democracy is something that you do
yourself or for which you take risks had
receded so far out of our imagination
that we couldn't really imagine that a
country would take risks for democracy
now of course I'm citing the example
which is close to me there are many
other people around the world taking
risks now for freedom for example women
in Iran what I'm trying to say is that
that ethical point that democracy is
about wanting democracy uh is essential
without that nothing else matters
without the ability to think of
democracy as a verb as something that
you do as something for which you'll
take risks nothing else matters if
there's that commitment if we think of
democracy as something for which we take
responsibility every time we speak the
word as opposed to something that's just
coming to us then it's like we're doing
politics in a different dimension a
fifth dimension of ethics and once we've
done that we can start to speak about
how we would change the larger forces
once we make that commitment then we can
say some basic things like for example
we have to also have the fourth
dimension the fourth dimension of time
we need to have a sense of the future
for democracy we have to care for the
Earth we have to care specifically about
global warming because if the future
collapses in on us it becomes impossible
to have the kind of reasonable
conversation that we need for democracy
we also need the fourth dimension in the
sense of the past we have to have
history we have to be able to reckon
with forces like for example colonialism
which is so important in the Russian
invasion of Ukraine but also so
important in the history of the United
States if we if we need the past so that
we can reckon with ourselves and
self-correct because self-correction is
what democratic decision making is all
about
we also need the first three dimensions
be simply being able to move about in
the world in all the senses of moving
about that one can imagine and all of
those ways of moving about are hindered
by economic inequality economic
inequality oligarchy makes it very hard
to have conversations about democracy
the future or the past a lot of the
space is monopolized by things that are
simply ridiculous but but happen because
of the way that wealth is distributed
and economic inequality in very simple
sense also hinders social Mobility
economic advance
finally democracy at least in my country
but not only in my country has to be
understood as a spirit that is the way
that the laws should be interpreted the
way that the future should arrive rather
does a matter of legalism in the Supreme
Court of the United States but not only
this has advanced much further in other
countries like Hungary taking the
procedures as being more important than
the Democracy more important than the
right is a way of leading the country
away from democracy and in my country it
could lead us all the way away from
democracy as soon as the next couple of
years it doesn't have to do so we can
think about these larger structures we
can think in a non-legalistic and in a
more ethical way we can get our minds
around this maybe a good place to start
is and it's a sort of a big question but
just how how do we get to this place how
did we end up here where we are sort of
grappling with these these questions
especially you know you're you're based
in the United States as a lie and uh
Lots on on this um on this call are from
all over the world but I think are
struggling with these things and
wherever they are but how did we find
ourselves in this place I think in our
country we have a big empty middle space
uh between you know complacency like the
view that we just are a democracy
because we're America you know that by
definition we're or the past has given
it to us the founding fathers did
something two and a half centuries ago
and therefore we just are a democracy or
as I said we have capitalism therefore
we just are a democracy are we just say
it over and over again now from our
democracy right we have this kind of we
have various flavors of exceptionalism
we have we have that
um and then on the other side we have a
history that reminds us of how difficult
it's been for us to be a democracy where
women were excluded from the vote for
more than half of the history of the
country where African-Americans are
still de facto excluded from the vote in
in much of the country right it's the
the entire thing has been a struggle so
there's this there's this gap which can
only be filled I think by by historical
knowledge and in biethics I think we've
had trouble getting through that Gap
partly because in the last 30 years we
sort of convinced ourselves that the
facts about the past don't really matter
and then the other thing which I think
is going on which is related is that
people are so worried about the future
that it's hard for them to imagine that
like counting votes and representation
and these basic things are really what
matters and I think that you know
everyone is almost everyone is afraid of
the future whether you know you're
afraid of climate change what I think is
reasonable or whether you're afraid of
demography which I think is not
reasonable it's all part of one big
sense that the future is crashing down
and if you think the future is crashing
down then you know democracy becomes a
kind of secondary concern and then you
kind of look up and look around you
think ah it's slipping away
well I mean I think to this idea of
thinking about the future
um so in in 2017 You released um the
book on tyranny which was positioned as
a sort of a guide to
um resistance and you start that book by
saying um history does not repeat but it
does instruct and I'm curious just maybe
as a place to to jump off to other
questions
um to think about how you as a historian
who gives a lot of thought to the
current moment
um use that thinking to guide you oh
thank you that's a really kind question
I appreciate the assumption that history
that history matters I I think you've
named the way that history matters the
most which is which is pattern
recognition so for example when when
when the book was invented
that caused 150 years of mental chaos in
a religious war and now books are a very
nice thing right now we all we all love
books and we're in the internet and
we're we're kind of in that same stage
where it's causing all sorts of chaos
eventually we'll probably get it under
control but we shouldn't be surprised
it's causing all kinds of Chaos
another another good example is is um
the way that the historically speaking
the people who have cared about
democracy have also been the ones who
have talked about risk
um and that's you know I I cited
Frederick Douglass there's a whole
African-American tradition of this but
there's also a there's also a deep
tradition which goes all the way back to
the beginning of the word democracy in
Ancient Greece where when Pericles is
talking about democracy he can't talk
about democracy without physical risk
um he there's not an assumption that
democracy is just brought there's
there's there's the conviction this is
important there's the conviction that
it's better
and then there's the assumption that it
will take lots of work right and that
you know democracy doesn't usually fails
history shows us it usually fails but
when it's out there when it's when it's
on the rise there's this knowledge that
is difficult and then there's this
conviction that it's better and I in my
talk my little tiny talk I was trying to
get across like this conviction like you
have to you can't just say it's like out
there and it's either there it's not
there because the moment that you think
it's brought by the outside forces if
the outside forces aren't going your way
then you just turn tail and run but if
you think actually I'm convinced this is
much better than the Alternatives then
you might react a little bit differently
it's better but um harder I I you know I
think that that's been harder better but
harder um well so you know your um
you have a book out now the roads on
freedom and it looks at basically how
tyranny
um has been able to thrive in in spaces
in in Europe particularly you know you
talk a lot about Russia
um and some this book came out in 2018
which preceded the war in Ukraine um but
there are a lot of things there that I
can sort of signpost what what's really
to come and uh what's been happening
there for
um as you detail many many decades and
you know I think one thing that you
outline in there is this idea of two
different types of uh tyrannical
politics that I think uh is sort of
helpful in thinking about
um how we might see these threats to
democracy that are happening globally
um you know you talk about this idea of
inevitability politics and Eternity
politics and I'd love for you to spend a
few minutes of sort of describing these
two how do they come to exist and and
what is the the threat that they each
pose yeah thank you for that so the
politics of inevitability is what I was
talking about
earlier in my little talk just without
using the name it's the idea that
everything is coming to you it's the
idea of progress It's the idea that
there are no Alternatives the history
that history is over and that we're all
just kind of on a vector where things
are going to turn out okay
and the problem with that is not just
that it's not true but that it paves the
way for worse things so if you think
there's only one future it's a short
step to thinking there are no Futures if
you think technology is always going to
be good it's it's very easy not to
notice when technology starts to turn
against you or against democracy if you
think capitalism is going to bring
democracy then you're not going to be as
alert to inequality as you should be or
you might even say inequality is fine
it's a sign the system is working which
is I think completely completely wrong
and then at some point all of this snaps
and you lose the one future you thought
you had and you make a turn towards as
we've already seen in the US a politics
of Eternity where suddenly nobody's
talking about the future everything's a
cycle back towards the past uh the
leading politicians are talking about
how to make the country great again you
know which is I think senseless
um the the ability to make connections
across across different kinds of people
is lost because it's all about it's all
about Nostalgia and it's about the
Innocence that we once lost rather than
the good policy that we might make and
then there's a third kind of politics
which follows which follows after that
which we're edging into if we're not
very careful I think it was the politics
of catastrophe because one of the
features the politics of Eternity is it
almost always denies climate change
the politics of inevitability says yeah
there's climate change but it's going to
be okay we're going to figure it out the
politics of Eternity tends to deny
science in general and climate change in
particular which then sets us up for
something much worse right you can
pretend that politics is all about the
past but while you're doing that climate
change is still happening and that means
that a real catastrophe is coming so the
politics of Eternity sets us up for
something which is worse even
and I mean you have detailed how sort of
these um types of politics and including
the politics of catastrophe have existed
for quite some time and I I think when
you think about
um this moment that we're in right now
and uh sort of the present threats that
might exist to democracy how do you
compare the way that we're experiencing
these types of politics today versus
other moments in history for instance
around either of the world wars or
um you know when you think about the
Great Depression other Global crises um
how are we positioned in a better place
or worse
that's a great question too I think one
way that it's better is that we do have
the history so like things aren't
exactly like
things aren't exactly like 1917 or 1939
but when we have that history we can at
least look for some patterns and if
we're serious about it then we realize
that oh look there were moments where it
seemed like the larger forces had were
definitely pushing away from democracy
and those larger forces are important
you know you can you can recognize them
you can say aha economic inequality
mattered a huge amount in the 1930s and
it certainly did
um the the sense that there was no
future mattered a huge amount in the
1930s I made it very tough for for
democracies but we can also see that
democracies came back from that right
that democracies recovered from that
countries which were at the very bottom
like Germany within a few decades were
at the very top we were considering how
well their democracies work so we have
that history where we can diagnose and
we can see that recovery is possible and
I think that does give us an advantage
if we if we choose to use that Advantage
I mean one of the things I worry about
us is that we tend to say like
everything is new like nothing has
happened before and of course nothing's
exactly like what's happened before but
the but the past gives us this terrific
possibility to say okay things can go
very very very wrong they can go so
wrong that it seems hopeless and yet
recoveries can be staged well 10
remember Pedro asked something that's uh
someone connected to this um they say
the forces against democracy today make
use of Advanced Technologies and methods
and the dare I say romantic Democratic
behavior of speaking acting protesting
don't seem to be enough what do you
think about a more proactive or even
defensive democracy like we see in
Germany for instance do we need to do
more to update mindsets
uh yeah I'm All Aboard for that
um number one
I'm gonna go back to my obscure book
comparison because this is one of the
things that historians do so if you if
we look at the book like I'm looking at
a bunch of books if look at my
background they're a bunch of books
they're they're in covers they have
copyright they have authors all that
stuff had to be invented when the
printing press was created there wasn't
copyright there was an authorship there
was all kinds of plagiarism and slander
and libel and abuse and it did in fact
lead to war it led to Wars in which a
third of the population of Europe were
killed right so here we are again with
another Communications technology and
with this other Communications
technology we cannot think oh let's just
let it do whatever it does and like the
magical free market of blah blah you
know there is no magical free market of
blah blah you have to have conventions
at which it which allow people to
express themselves in a way which is
consistent with basic decency and with
the kinds of Institutions that you want
to have like democracy so the the the
the web is set up the internet is set up
in the way it is basically accidentally
there's no reason to say like oh this
accident has some kind of foundational
magical power and it can't be changed
there's no reason why social media it
has to be the way that it is right now
there's no reason why Facebook for
example can't propose that um that you
know algorithmically that you go to
local investigative reporting there's no
reason why we can't use proceeds from
social media's huge profits to to prop
up that local media reporting which
would give people access to facts in
other words it's it's it's a kind of
magical thinking to say that like the
internet is the way that the internet
has to be and you know this is so I I'm
very much on board with that because I
think I I think that you one of the
things we got wrong in the last 30 years
was the idea that like this quote
unquote high technology would definitely
would necessarily Advance us but in fact
a lot of this high technology is
basically incredibly low-tech
behaviorist brain hacks which are just
carried out on a massive scale and have
the result that people find themselves
more alienated more isolated and with
more extreme views the then they would
have had otherwise and so if we take the
position that I started with namely that
democracy is a good thing and we should
try we need to commit ourselves to it
take responsibility for it then we
should say you know what it's actually
not that important that big profitable
countries get to carry out you know
infinitely scaled behaviorist brain
hacks that's not that important what's
important is that we have means of
communicating with one another which
actually allow us to have the kinds of
political systems which are worth
valuing so I mean yes is my answer to
that question and Ted member tord asks
you know processing narratives that
support your beliefs rather than facts
is a big issue for the U.S and other
countries historically what has been the
self-correcting process to move back
towards fact based judgments which I
think is in some ways connected to this
idea of the ways we use social media
yeah that question is I'm gonna not
repeat myself but that question is bang
on and one of the answers is we have to
change the algorithms
um but another answer is that we used to
have not just in the US but in other
countries too although it's really
striking here we used to have investment
of reporting and we really don't anymore
we're in this very weird situation where
all of us stare at screens all day long
and what we're looking for is the news
you know and me too I do this too I'm
looking for like the latest thing that's
happened in some some region of Ukraine
but we don't we don't actually have our
system set up in such a way as to make
it make it a way that people can make a
living to actually go hunt down those
stories so we have this mechanism the
internet which which reproduces and
which spins and which aims for profit
and and the reason the facts are
important is not just so that you kind
of have them it's also because facts are
surprising like if the only thing that
can challenge a narrative is a fact my
narrative your narrative doesn't matter
but if there aren't any facts our
narratives are just going to rush
forward unchallenged right and we know
very well that if I have a narrative and
you have a narrative those two
narratives aren't going to correct each
other the only thing that corrects the
narratives is is surprising things that
come in from the outside which you're
not really ready for but what you kind
of can't deny are may be true right like
that there's mercury in your water or
that your city council member just took
a fifty thousand dollar bribe you know
or whatever it is those things you're
not going to find out about the
investigative reporting so I I I agree
with that with a premise this question
I'm just gonna give investigative
reporting as as my answer there are
other answers but I'm going to move on
because I know there are other questions
um we we still have a lot of great
member questions coming in um so this
one sort of uh looks at an issue that we
haven't gotten into very much yet um Ted
member or Gabriella asks how serious is
the role of fossil fuels particularly
oil and threatening democracies in
countries all over the world and
consequently basic human rights uh it'll
yeah it'll bring it to an end I mean one
of the one of the categories that I use
in my book road to unfreedom and in the
new book that I'm writing which is a
philosophy book about Freedom where I'm
trying to sketch out a positive view of
freedom and what Freedom actually is and
how we could get there and how the world
could be better
um is one of the concepts I use in these
books is hydrocarbon oligarchy you know
which or actually I think I've stripped
it down to Fossil oligarchy because that
sounds a little bit I don't know maybe
maybe a little more more easy to grasp
or something but I completely agree
we're never the the hydrocarbons first
of all as I said before they collapse
the future and democracy needs a future
It's Like Oxygen for democracy I mean if
you'll forgive the simple metaphor like
it's like you can't if you can't see a
future then you don't see the point of
negotiations and long conversations and
balances and you know you've started if
you don't see the future then you think
I've got to take something right now you
know I've got to take something right
now which is where climate change will
inevitably drive most of us I mean
climate change is going to affect the
the the the least privileged people
first and it's already doing that and
but it will eventually drive all of us
um into this into this space where we
think okay I I don't have time to talk
I've gotta like I have to look after
number one I gotta look after my
children I have to take what I can take
and in that Spirit democracy can't
Thrive and then and secondly hydrocarbon
oligarchy leads to a situation where you
have these these people who whether they
have to be dictators or not have this
you know sort of whimsical power over
the rest of us
uh so so Vladimir Putin is the world's
leading hydrocarbon oligarchy oligarch
and like other hydrocarbon oligarchs he
has weird eye weird political ideas he's
not the only one though right I mean the
there are hydrocarbon oligarchs in
hydrocarbon oligarchs in the United
States who thinks things like well there
shouldn't really be a government and
everything would be fine and let's all
be Libertarians even though the only
reason they have their own rights to
exploit is that the state intervened on
behalf of them or their company or their
predecessors at some point so
um hydrocarbon hydrocarbons tend to
concentrate wealth and by concentrating
wealth they also warp conversations and
we end up we end up then dealing with
Russia invading Ukraine which wouldn't
be possible without hydrocarbon
dependency or we end up in the U.S with
these weird conversations about whether
there should be a government or not you
know which which wouldn't be possible we
end up in the fact the United States
um money has a vote or money money is
considered to have freedom of speech is
a direct result of hydrocarbon oligarchy
it's a direct result of that right so no
democracy will not make it with
hydrocarbons and I I I think these
things are a very intimate relationship
where we we have to move on to different
kinds of fuels not just because of
simple physical survival but also in
order to protect or really to advance or
to make possible the kind of Freedom we
would want in the future
and we have a question from Ted member
Tao which um I find really understand
really interested to hear what how you
respond to this um they ask why should
democracy survive democracies have
proved to be unstable corrupt filled
with voter ignorance and finally to not
prevent Wars or violence why should we
hold on to this imperfect ideal and not
instead make room for a new system that
might emerge it's a paraphrase when it's
in structural the new systems that are
emerging are all just a hell of a lot
worse
um on all those criteria which were just
mentioned whether it was corruption or
ignorance or disinterest of Voters there
wouldn't be any more voters to be
disinterested for one thing so I mean if
we could look off at planet Venus and
say well gosh there's a system where
people are happier and Freer and live
longer lives in their democracies then
maybe yeah but I'm looking at the really
existing Alternatives like China and
Russia and so on which are pushing
um as themselves as a kind of model in
the world that we actually live in and
then all the criteria that were just
mentioned they they do they do worse so
uh the reason that I mean but I
appreciate the question because of the
should part of it because I think it's
indispensable in these conversations to
answer the should question the reason
why I think democracy is a better kind
of system is not because it's perfect
obviously it's because I think that it
as a conceptual and ethical framework
gives us a place to aim for where we
then it we then can end up with better
things that we have so premise number
one
um democracies are flawed but they can
be made better or worse and if you if
you say oh they're all just doomed or
they're not really any better than like
you know they're not really any better
than dying young in a prison in Russia
or whatever where they're not really any
better than being observed your entire
life from Cradle to grave and being
homogenized like in China if you start
from that you know start from that
premise then you're not going to get
anywhere but whereas democracy is the
idea that the people will rule and I
think that's a better idea than that the
people will not rule and the reason why
I think it's a better idea is I actually
I believe in that since there's
something special about humans where we
prosper and Thrive and add something to
the universe when we're free and I think
democracy is the best framework for that
an improving democracy about a better a
better democracy that's that's the first
premise right that that the things the
fact that things are imperfect doesn't
mean that you toss them away and the the
second premise is that um these
alternatives are actually really bad so
there's like I'd be happy to make room
for I'm happy to make room for better
forms of representation I've had to make
room for local assemblies but I'm not
happy to make room for hydrocarbon
oligarchy I'm not happy to make ready
make room for for one party rule you
know I'm not happy to make room for the
things which are actually out there and
we actually have a couple of questions
from a couple of members about
um kids and children basically how to
help them think about democracy from
both 10-member Arena attend number DK
how do we teach our kids uh to quote
unquote do democracy yeah I love I love
I love that question it's one that I
it's one that I struggle with all the
time but also it's one where I learn
things from my own kids all the time
like they say some pretty some pretty
fresh things which which helped me out
some pretty clarifying things uh so with
I mean with kids
look I think you you teach you T you
have if you're if you're dealing with
young people so I don't I I deal with
younger people in my line of work and
like they can maybe you know tell me how
wrong I am but um but my general sense
is you can't tell young people students
or kids that everything's gonna be okay
like the politics of inevitability is
obviously dead and so stories about how
you know everything's gonna be okay
whether it's like studying Martin Luther
King or whether it's referring to the
not you know the founding fathers I
think that's off the table I I think you
have to talk about democracy as a
struggle where there are really good
examples and you and you teach and you
teach the examples of democracy I do
think it's important in teaching it as a
struggle to also be teaching it as as an
ideal so America could be a democracy
here's some of the ways that people have
pushed in that direction in the past
here's some of the ways that we need to
be pushing in the future and sorry that
I'm talking about America it's just that
when like as soon as kids come in I I
narrow down right right right away to my
own country
um so that it's a struggle and that it's
that it's uh that it's a that's a
possible future but I think maybe even
more important than all those things is
um modeling democracy not in the sense
that you have a vote about what you do
with your kids because then it's okay
it's always like let's eat a bag of
candy or whatever but like not not in
the not in the narrow sense but modeling
democracy in the sense of
um uh in in the way that parents talk
with their friends and in the way that
like people around the house behave you
that you get a sense of like horizontal
conversation and different interests
being taken into account and and things
like that that's about as well as I
could do I mean if I like if I had a
magical answer to this I'm sure my
children would be much better behaved
than they than they are um but but I
mean to repeat like I think in a way
it's like kind of the other way around
like I try really hard to make sure I am
listening to my kids
um because in a way this is kind of all
this is all about them like the big
collapse that could happen where
democracy and climate and all these
things get intertwined you know when we
I mean one of the premises of my book
which you're kind enough to ask about is
that
um is that we will either be free and
secure or we will
die under tyranny that freedom and
security go together I think that
freedom democracy security actually go
together if we're going to get out from
under climate change it's going to be as
free people and if we end up in in
tyrannies
um that those things are going to tend
to accelerate climate change and profit
from it so like there's a negative
intertwining over here and a positive
one over here I think that's something
that we can stress with kids right like
not say oh you're going to be in this
terrible future where you're gonna have
to choose between security and freedom
which is a very bad habit I think I
think we have to teach look if we get
the freedom part right the Democracy
part right we can get the climate part
right and if we get the climate part
right that's going to help us get the
Democracy part right
[Music]
foreign